foreign
[Music]
this is my question then do you think
it's going to get to a point right where
if we start losing jobs right and
there's less jobs and more people are on
like only fans right that you're
basically have chicks out there like
literally people women holding each
other at gunpoint like you know
subscribe to my [__] stuff like that
like
you know what I'm saying like I don't
know what you're saying you know help
Jamie can you pull up some help
I need some help man did you play any
sports in high school I played
basketball
and then we're good you know I was good
so you were an expert at hamsters and
basketball
I would say I was an expert at
definitely guinea pigs gerbils hamsters
anything you know rodentia
once you popped up into like rabbits I
was out when you you're right okay buddy
what happened was that a hate crime are
we gay which one of the polls you think
uh
will live longer
it's an easy answer but uh we can do it
anyway I heard Logan say he wants to
like live forever or some [__] once I
could see that
yeah he seemed like a guy that will want
to live forever who would you fight if
you had to fight one of them I'd
probably fight the sister I think is
there a sister RuPaul
who's that oh wait who's that I bagged
that [__] up son do you have any black
friends I have one or two okay how do
you not know if you have one or two
though right yeah
second there's blacks around I know how
many there are
I used to go get high with my buddies
right my buddy his dad was kind of like
he didn't know a lot about gays or
anything he didn't believe in it right
so sometimes I go outside and get high
with his son
and then I would come back in early
right and I would tell the dad I'd be
like man
we were outside and some of the guys had
their shirts off and they were just
I don't know Mr Mike they were being
kind of crazy I felt like or strange and
you could see him [__] start to light
up because he thought it was like some
kind of gay activity
right so they would come and they'd be
stoned out their gills right they have
no idea I've been talking to the dad and
he'd be like you boys been queering
around
he would [__] lose his [__] dude you
could see him his friend waiting to yell
it and everybody's just standing there
just stoned and I am laughing so hard
because I made that moment happen you
know anyway so he's [__] crazy and uh
apparently he bit a hooker like that's
like his big fault
right but here's what happened a hooker
bit onto him so how do you get a hooker
off of you you bite her or push you
can't there's not like a hooker removal
thing you know like there's to get snow
off your car right
you know so he bit her back I'm guessing
he might ever you know he's excessive
but you got to get a hooker off you yeah
have you ever had that problem I have
not have had some maybe issues with some
you know aggressive escorts I'd call
them
but I wouldn't say hookers really I
think if you have a diploma you're not a
hooker yeah
why are you looking at me
oh I saw an owl get hit by a tow truck
uh in Indianapolis a couple of weeks ago
Theo's getting ready to write a book and
that's going to be his chapter one
driving along a road
and they had an owl come up from the
wood line a beautiful owl you know just
the Lord's bird and it came right up and
then uh
I don't know what I was thinking about
pornography but then a tow truck hit it
a tow truck hit it doing 60 miles an
hour sir and uh
and so I'm a huge Harry Potter fan
and so immediately I was like man I need
to go back and see what's going on you
know and so I went back around and I get
back close to it and uh that's when I
realized that hey I don't even like
animals at all and you're wasting your
feet that it looked like it was gonna
die and so I uh
I rolled down my window a little and I
asked if it was all right and I was like
are you all right I'll he said
and I said you owl this is no time to be
playing games you've been hit by a tow
truck
and I asked again and he didn't give
anything not a not a talent or nothing
and uh
and so then I knew he was going to die
and so I just asked what we all wanted
to ask how many licks does it take to
get to the center of a Tootsie pop what
a jerk what embarrasses you oh I already
know this what
if people see my butt have you ever been
to a black church oh yeah those get you
fired up oh dude black church is
definitely
yeah you like feel the Lord oh you feel
the Lord and somebody will Splash
[__] hot grease like you don't even
know what's going on like you don't know
if somebody just like ripped open like a
lunch plate real fast ladies like
whipped her hair yeah like you'll see a
black lady she'll have a [__] plant
she'll be watering a plant in her hay
during the [__] sermon dude people
are dressed up you a grape or something
oh everybody smells good dude the Lord
will pass through the room I mean man it
had a Arc start out slow you feel the
closing bit then it's the grand finale
and I just want to throw my wall in the
damn air and be like I'm converted and
then you throw it out there oh I'll
throw my apartment yeah yeah I'll throw
my [__] dick in the air and catch it
in my mouth dude
you know what I'm saying if if if it
calls for it but I'm like God calls for
it if God calls for that I didn't know
this I'm not a good driver I didn't know
like flashing Reds you were supposed to
stop so I just like plowed through it
wait a second hold on hold on hold on
what
what did you think flashing red meant I
thought
yeah slow down a little bit look around
it's optional
and I lost a tooth yesterday yeah you've
been how many challenges were you on for
MTV you did a lot you never lost any you
never got hurt or anything no I never
got hurt but here's my tooth actually
stand up don't stand up so it's kind of
nice that's really disgusting oh we're
going to touch up thank you Stacy's all
over a little bit of uh what is that
enamel what is that you want to see a
tooth impersonation watch this hold on
all right here it comes
the hand you were given you've seen the
show oh my God I have a real tooth
um anyway but it's nice actually because
then we went out to the bars last night
and I like put like if I was going to
talk like a cute chick I would put it in
yeah and if I was going to talk to a
busted chick then I would leave it out
the first funeral I ever went to man was
a black guy
he um
died he was the biggest guy in our town
his name was Ricardo he was like uh a
man child it was like as if you saw like
a nine-year-old child but he was like I
mean he's probably six four damn he was
the biggest he was the biggest kid in
our town he was oh oh you've never seen
nothing like it they didn't have it you
know when you see I've just been the
mayor oh he was I mean he definitely he
could [__] keep the sun off of you
he was [__] big I mean he [__] [__]
up in DodgeBall oh dude he was just he
could do whatever he want the birds knew
him the birds don't I mean you see a
bird come [__]
big dude he was big and so how'd he
passed he was playing basketball it was
like a little league basketball game Big
Boy Little League 11 and 12 year olds
and uh he had a heart attack and die
really was he was he all Natty or is he
on the roids he wasn't on anything he
was just on just too much I think he had
did his heart they said he had an
enlarged heart I don't know what that
means what does that mean just the heart
of a grown man in a young boy's body it
could have been it I wish I had a grown
man's penis when I was 12. do you kinda
oh you don't want just because then I
had that you had that or you have it I
had it as a child as a child yeah did
you know that yeah [__] what I know that
oh
all right
listen here there's one you want this
which one you want this one okay
one's in the chamber the old one's in
the chamber oh yeah
oh yeah
what is it like like I am in that Oak
over there and you'll see that red dot
just shoot no no don't shoot don't shoot
no no don't shoot don't keep it keeping
off the trigger okay all right I see
what I'm saying you can see how you can
see the Red Dot the red dotic on his
hands all right and who's the other team
it's just us just
why do I even have kids is what I can
understand they don't like them they
don't care for them they do all the
wrong [__] and abuse them too why even
have them I don't know why I think
because they kind of like puppies they
look cute for a while oh I think that is
a lot of they want them to get to hold
that sign first grade
second grade dude the best was in my
neighborhood somebody did that they put
their picture on Facebook as a kid and
he had second grade two times and I was
like
you can do it Robert they wrote at the
bottom and we know we can't do it dude
but he's gonna try there were also some
tips and tricks like never take the
roadside test that's just Gathering
evidence against you totally get tell
more people as they drink here tonight
give us all a little tutorial no that's
good if you if you did Drive don't
forget your car
that's a really big one have you ever
heard of like those old things like you
put a little nickel a couple nickels and
some pennies under your tongue you can
blow you know zero what the [__] and
what you could blow a Jewish guy yeah
your favorite race
to like sleep with I don't know you know
I've only honestly I probably slept with
predominantly white women
some women don't like I think some women
just don't like their they don't they
don't like keep them on to you like I
I've never had sex with a black chick
yeah I've just never like I've hooked up
with one but I've never I don't have my
black belt well I don't want to [__]
somebody who's on FaceTime the whole
time hey
and B here's the craziest part is though
some black women it seemed like they
[__] back dog that's the thing I don't
know that's what I'm saying yeah it's
kind of intimidating yes I don't know if
I can handle it bro you got to be like
it's like kind of like do you want this
jail like yeah
I don't think I got this I don't I'm not
that guy bro you know I'm saying I I
would but I don't think
I just don't wanna it's like I don't
wanna under you know I'm all
underwhelmed yeah I don't want to
underwhelm bro bro what you gonna get
for Christmas
I don't know my sister just asked me
today but I didn't I don't want to text
her back dude I just
I'd rather not get anything from her you
should ask Santa Claus for a mustache
I think he looks good what's wrong with
this look he knows his mustache drinking
beer
huh I wish I could drink beer man
Louisiana I know but I'll buy cocaine
man I'm gonna I'm addicted to drugs and
alcohol so if I have a half a beer dude
I will have seven bottles of cocaine
yeah so
I can't do it but what am I getting for
Christmas I know what I'm getting dude
I'm getting a shirt my brother's getting
me a shirt
um
yeah and what else man what kind of
shirt huh what kind of shirt a large
large shirt
this [__] crazy no it's true do
you birds were like wolves wolves hunt
at the moon
no but my mother does though to deal
with an abusive husband back in the day
before women had any other way of
dealing with it well you'd get your
brothers and they'd just you know beat
him to death and then they you know you
know you hide them yeah so that's what
people have done forever or with a PDO
file as you say like Pedialyte well yeah
both for children did you go to your
prom
yeah yeah I did was it fun
dude I'll tell you what happened was
they had this guy at our school
and he was always kind of crying and
everything and I cried some but this guy
really was it a teacher no man this was
a young man student
this guy really patented and I feel like
and he
it was we were graduating you know not
long after and he's like I want to
change my dreams and
I don't know if I'm a
if I'm brave enough to and people always
this white guy bald-headed right yeah
something happened to him right he's
always like people always tell me I look
like Damon Wayans that's what he said so
bro I got stuck with that dude after the
problem he's crying in a car why did you
get stuck with him I was just listening
to him you know just trying to be
supportive where was your date
she was at the party getting drunk
and uh by the time I got to the party
she got everybody gotten kicked out
so for an hour I sat there listening to
this guy
and he had um you know the uh
back when they had coats with the
shoulder pads in them yeah he wore that
to the prom with like these extra
shoulder bags he was just kind of like
an insecure guy you sure he wasn't on
the football team no he wasn't not bro
unless the football team had a concierge
playing tailback before I did comedy
like I was heavily involved in the
Paralympics okay what were you doing in
the Paralympics I was a sprinter man for
uh
oh my God oh my God how many features
you would beat my ass in a race I think
so
except let me tell you something dude I
would show you might think oh Tony's
funny he'll probably show some mercy on
me he'll probably jog a little bit and
then work let me catch up nope
[__] I will leave you in these
straight up [__] dust dude bro calm
down dude no I will not I will not I
will not
wearing a [__] diaper and [__] it
ain't happening dude bro God wrote his
legs in cursive dude give him a break
my sister used to have a bass that was
in their house and it was like
it couldn't even turn around in the tank
oh that's [__] up I don't think it
minded I bet it did
I don't know of course it did it lived
there for a long time that's what they
say the guys in solitary I don't think
he Minds oh yes sir it's by himself in
there especially if it's a bass he can't
talk to him you know he's probably like
get me the [__] out of here I want to be
on a lake I want to be eating frogs you
[__] he's just watching cops out of one
eye with my sister
he's watching 90 Day Fiance what the
[__] is wrong with people keep me in
this goddamn Bowl I'm a bass it's stupid
[__]
I used to have piranhas yeah of course
you did man who doesn't think you did
world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out